hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 okay I fiddled with the weapons
a bit so now I have my good old
fashioned plasma cutter with the Tesla
core which does fires little beams of
electricity I'm guessing and then I
changed up this so I got the military
engine on top and the second plasma core
that I got on the bottom in shotgun
format so it's it's it's the force gun I
can knock him down then take him apart
with my machine gun so that's good let's
hope that that helps me out a little
better than what it did before because
everything else is seemingly useless to
me but now that I know that Ellie has
moved on now I Isaac Clark I can go
forward don't be sorry I mean that was
quick the world is ending and all you
can think about it ah damn right I never
gave up on you oh no you get up on the
world I paid my dues or don't you think
I'm [ __ ] up enough already
Isaac this is what stuck without your
help
are you with me doesn't look like I have
a choice
now ah relationship trauma aboard the
USS nightmare oh boy what's going on
don't [ __ ] with me what ha ha no don't
oh no you don't I got the superior power
of mouse aiming here you will not break
me where the hell do these guys come
from there weren't enough people on the
ship to create this I mean their need
they need organic matter to do this
don't they is that yellow I can't tell
if that's actually yellow or if that's I
think it might be but I can't tell
no I don't think it is sorry oh I get it
I'm an idiot dirt oh good boy oh come on
let go
look out thank you hold it
come on
thank you
stasis enemies whoa hello
oh come on damn reload shut up
there we go bunch of ill
here we wha no it's much better that was
just for extra gusto
anyone else want to step and think so ah
no one's gonna mess with Isaac Clark
while he's working
nothing hey my gosh cut you up hard oh
hello heard some oh hi hang on Jesus
hold your horses
I got business to attend to
oh [ __ ] alright that takes care of that
hello switch weapons here last one where
did you come from you a-hole ah yes I
miss every time I didn't even need to do
that I could have hit them easily I
think they definitely reduce the power
of the plasma cutter either that or I've
got no I'm god I really need to upgrade
my stuff I think I think that's what I
need to do man I went a long way for a
short drink of water long way for a
small drink well I don't know what the
saying is I went a long way I could've
just jumped across the chasm I've done
crazier stuff I mean me Isaac Clark has
done crazier stuff than that
all right anyway carrying on this ship
has certainly gone to hell which way am
I going here that way that was the only
way to go I'm an idiot
Oh God
uh hi okay oh yeah ah good old spinning
blades of doom
sounds familiar yep yep oh wow it's a
bit too close for comfort I think on all
secure here okay the other still lid
I'll meet you at the Admirals quarters
don't leave me waiting uh-huh Wow Carter
sounds kind of like a douche I'm a
feeling that he's gonna go insane trying
to figure out what
whoa what is my altar that fire do here
man I don't even know what my alternate
fire does it seems like the most piddly
little team of energy I've ever seen in
my life okay what's all this son what is
a electrical engineering interface I
don't remember this at all
what oh it's a puzzle wait hang on wait
a minute what all right what oh you
didn't even explain the rules to me what
am I supposed to do here oh okay oh okay
all right then I gotta use a mouse and
the keyboard to move these things which
is kind of kind of weird but not totally
foreign to me come on come on hey come
on what the hell I'm trying to move it
it wouldn't let me go laughs why it
wouldn't let me go right what the hell
what man this is weird okay I'm trying
to do these things exactly the way it's
telling me to
but for some reason there we go [ __ ]
come on there we go man oh no that's
wrong there we go that was a little
counterintuitive don't you think I mean
that would have been great with an Xbox
controller but it doesn't work the same
way for a PJ because with Xbox I bet it
I bet with Xbox is just double it's just
the two joysticks or Playstation 2 two
joysticks - yo Bank Bank Bank bank and
it would have been super easy this I got
to think about I don't know my fingers -
my wrist movement they don't they don't
equate
it's a skill I've never had to
coordinate for and that is a [ __ ] on the
wall oh this is the captain's quarters
okay
le carré votes in breach the Admirals
quarters Isaac's turn hey Isaac Isaac
cava what's going on Isaac
hey turn hey what is it what going on
and I see nothing everything's fine
everything's fine
Ellie the Admiral was obsessed with
making a key a keeper walk
Hey a key to what some sort of alien
device
machine I think that she believed that I
controlled markers oh my god she wanted
to turn it off she wrote that over and
over again like a mantra or instructions
this is exactly what we've been looking
for this isn't just some random planet
Isaac
they found the source the marker
homeworld you've got to be shitty
alright let's regroup in the control
room we can plan our next move from
there Clark
shake it off let's go car damn things
are just getting interesting like I said
before I absolutely love the story of of
everything about hello fighting the war
back home uh-huh
now can somebody tell me for the love of
God what the hell we're looking for
we're looking for hope general aha good
support for the war and our ability to
fight it are dwindling we are out of
resources we are out of public approval
and we are out of time just answer my
question what are we looking for buckle
here crack down a scrap transport shop
on the closure if we can get it
spaceworthy again we can use it to reach
the planet's surface no chance we find
the shuttle then we're getting the hell
out of here
damn it Robert if we don't stop the
markers there won't be anything to go
back to either way it looks like the
shuttles our only shot where is sounds
good to me with a bleed terranova it's a
long walk
well they must have some way to travel
between ships there's a way we'll find
it yeah I'm gonna go out into space by
myself
what what the hell just happened didn't
see anything how I heard was really
dramatic music okay anyway moving
forward anyway like I was saying I
really like uh I don't know graves asked
me to prepare this information for you
wait a minute when the black marker was
exhumed on the earth 22:14 he's defied
our understanding of science you can you
generate limitless energy ah Rito
obvious importance in our resource
struts time yeah there was an effort to
replicate the mark yeah we all know that
we all know that story you guys can look
that up on your own later Wow [ __ ] you
Oh strategic dismemberment indeed man
it's weird this plasma cutter doesn't
seem like the same gun as before because
I mean the plasma cutter of old used to
actually
Bosh Bosh whatever this does I don't
actually know Sarla getting back in my
own rhythm here remembering how to play
and how to play effectively anyway the
plasma cutter of old actually put out
you know kind of a beam and this one
just seems gonna be a bullet more than
anything I'm going the other way
weight was in here anyway a hollow I
almost miss that
I guess the new power nodes are weapon
modifications or something hey either
way good stuff shotgun I got to pay
attention to where I'm going because I
can easily overlook things like this
just walking towards my objective marker
gotta be better than that
oh it's you this wreck yes Santa's tell
him what we found of course we found a
lipid maintenance cross a skip it
doesn't go very far or very fast but it
will take you to the outcome of ships
okay
yeah I'm sending you the coordinates now
let's get the shuttle so we can head
home already
okie dokie we are not going home hello
whoa hey we'll get the show first and
decide what to do with it Tom totally
not looking at her boobs
knowledge good alright so we got
ourselves a bit of a conundrum here
we've got a shuttlecraft that we need to
go to but I'm pretty sure the conundrum
we get that everything in Dead Space has
a tendency to explode as soon as Isaac
gets on it Oh soot kiosk see what I got
they said I got something for playing
dead space 1 & 2 so let's take a look e
leu we got a VA sued lightweight suit
divine for outdoor first contact suit
that's one of my special suits witness
suit hello
ha ha ha ha talk about paranoid
delusions I mean look at all the
markings on that thing ok let's look at
let's do that one that looks awesome I
want that one
that seems just right up Isaac's alley
he writes all these crazy symbols right
on his suit I don't know if it'd give
any other benefits other than it looked
kind of cool uh yeah that's what I'm
talking about
oh let's he forgot another face too this
is awesome hahaha I shouldn't like it as
much as I am okay let's see upgrade
health armor oxygen stasis Kinesis see
lots of scram l I don't want to get rid
of those just yet I want to get weapons
before I start upgrading that and my
health hasn't really been a problem so
far oh it's you are you contacting me on
a private channel I'm gonna stab you in
the back
besides I know you two had a fail but
she's mine now and I love her too much
to let her do this if she's right and
this is the month of the homeroom maybe
there's a chance of stopping this both
know how this is going down if they
found a way to stop the markers 200
years ago don't you think we'd all be
shaped by now uh-huh yeah whatever
what is make sure you thank you and her
yeah we're forgetting all right oh it's
oxygen
hahaha that's a classic size of paranoid
denial or whatever it is I'm not
psychologist shut up I don't know okay
so anyway cognition
oh yes I am going into space for Papa
Sierra do you guys hear this my rigs
thinking of some kind of looping message
it sounds encrypted it's coming from the
research vessel CMS Greely this could be
really important okay where is it I'll
check into it Santos Isaac out where
where is that is that somewhere optional
mission Oh explore the greeley I want to
check that out I want to be flying
around space just a little bit longer
let's um see I think I got that locked
in there let's see where that objective
is nope that didn't work okay explore
the greeley come on give me some hair
get me some huh get me some her what
that how do i how do i what how do i how
do i don't know how to switch ah ha come
on there's got to be a that's inventory
there we go see when I have a chance I
should check it out okay I want to now
how do I get to it I want to check it
out I really do I'm running out of air
here alright whatever this is good look
at other stuff I mean I'm floating out
in space it's really cool
oxygen let's grab some of this pull tabs
for dirt that's for access there we go
gummy gummy I'm taking you with me let's
see where is this ship that they are
talking about I don't see anything else
I want to use this optional quest
give me your ox head suck it out with my
mouth hole um I mean my mouth that's
what a minute
god I can't orient to ground okay there
are a lot of pass I don't see where it
is or where it could be that's back
towards the space station now you know
what I'll leave the secrets up to you
guys and for my second playthrough on my
own because I am gonna do a second
playthrough on my own eventually and who
knows it may just lead it to you I may
only be able to get to the ship once I
get in the ship that's probably what it
is
I'm an idiot that's probably what it is
skip load it up okay
okay ah ah that's the Greely that's what
I was going okay commence travel to
Greely thank you very much
I'm dumb figure let's see I could go to
this shuttle that I'm gonna use to get
other ships we're having to go fly like
Superman in space on my own now this is
interesting though sort of like a hub
mechanic in space you know a lot of
people were worried that you know dead
space wasn't gonna be in space but it
looks like a good bit of the first part
of the mission is gonna be in space so
this is pretty cool okay now let us act
we're looking on the greeley for
something I'm assuming important
probably probably important or not
that is the Greely I am on my way looks
like there's gonna be some creepy
crawlies on that machine I'm wondering
how the marker had influenced all the
way out here cuz I know for a fact that
the marker has a limited range
oh that see I knew it all of your stupid
things seem to be be getting a bit
better it shopping your limbs off thank
you he's gonna give me anything or he's
gonna stand there and look pretty you
know I'm wondering I'm actually kind of
concerned because they may be they may
look like dogs now because people didn't
like the fact that there were babies as
enemies and I don't know they're
obviously not babies anymore they're
monsters V form but I could see how some
people might be offended by that
okay move it for it I don't know why I I
need to use the Kinesis for everything
what happened to good old buttons hey
Santos I made it inside the Greeley
mmm-hmm
any luck with that encrypted message no
but if you can find the source maybe we
can find a way to decrypt it Roger that
Isaac out alright hahaha I seem to have
gotten two mice myself into another
situation where I am alone compact
standard frame I thought I already had
that okay alone on a ship on a mission
to find a message that probably I don't
need but here we are okay okay
where why what now up screw you baby I'm
still gonna call you up baby
Santos looks like parts of the ship are
sealed off on purpose do you think you
can get it open
not sure leave Tork bars power on I may
be able to lift the security lockdown
orc bars oh that's like the new power
node room torque bars torque bars God
called my torque bars my arms and my
torch bars okay I need a key card for
that one and pork bars for the other one
but having a good old power nodes all my
power nodes I like the power nodes I
thought power nodes were a good system
oh well can't have everything you want
but sometimes you might just find yeah
well you need but Hana oh boy yep
this appears to be the dark what's down
there I wonder I will find out in a
second alright that's the way I'm
supposed to go still it's up not best
way I'm only going nevermind alright
I wonder I'm actually curious if the
optional missions are all the more scary
stuff in the game because that way
people who want to play the game I think
that my I could picture a business
person making that decision where they'd
be like you want our game to be more
accessible so we make the main story not
as scary and then side missions have
them be the scary ones so I'm gonna play
all the side missions if I'm right hey
slow down
hey buddy whoa what are you oh you're a
spitter oh we're not a spinner spinners
from left 4 dead hello
slow down I'll take that but you missed
monkey all right
oh I wonder what cool things have
waiting for me this place and I wonder
if it actually affects the outcome of
the game maybe maybe there are more
interactive storytelling in this game
than I thought which will be awesome
shut up Ellie on the radio room just
give me a minute to release this
lockdown was that Ellie or Santos I
can't tell hard to tell through crappy
radio we got over here man I just I just
love the level design I like any type of
space type game hello oh boy a puzzle
all right use the arrow keys did Bala's
power between left and right systems
okay I see I gotta get them both in the
green nope overload CPU okay that gets
it's just a balancing act
damn too much power over the CPU don't
need 90 on the CPU need 45 yes maybe I
do need 9 hang on [ __ ]
hang on I got this I'm not an idiot no
[ __ ] oh my goodness
Cass this is complicated I don't
understand the equivalent exchange going
on here all right Leon that's the only
thing that doesn't overload that so let
me toss that over there says over here
did I do it broadcasting encoding method
planning time are you trying to contact
dr. Otto yeah dr. Serrano
all right some sort of torture going on
in there oh this looks good I don't have
a torque bar where do I get a torque bar
what does what come on what the hell you
gotta be [ __ ] kidding me why can't I
do anything to you oh man
Jesus stop it just leave me alone leave
me alone
good god what hit me what the [ __ ] just
hit me oh man I was panicky okay maybe I
make oh that's the same place wait I
just went in a big circle wait what oh
okay now I can go through here okay
hahaha man some all right moving forward
it oh boy what is this
oh I thought I heard some big I didn't
reload son of a [ __ ]
where are you where are you there you
are hang on I'm coming for you baby
whoosh Pro Dodd Wow get down
where are you though there you are
[ __ ] you're everywhere get off the walls
come on out of there stop hiding [ __ ]
ah can't even get to you you're just
stuck in there huh well come on now come
on out oh you son of a [ __ ] you're
kidding me I'm out of ammo
I'm enough you little [ __ ] bag hey ei I
found a bug I'm out of ammo holy [ __ ]
I'm out of ammo I have been using way
too much
what the hell out there okay that's what
it was ha ha ha
apparently ei if you knock a little guy
in to a thingy what is that
all right then uh I can still hear it
squirming around up there
come on all right
moving forward I slowed down
when I do that I should just stomp on
them that's always - Emma what I'm doing
right tear rip ah ah get off of me you
dick don't be stubborn ain't no get the
[ __ ] off of me
you son of a [ __ ] I'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of you with my bare hands
son of a [ __ ] okay yeah
things are getting much more closed
quarters in here Jesus what is that
music hey I know you give me my force
gun there we go I knew it had a purpose
right yes okay I don't either bench not
now I haven't gotten any more stuff
scheme oom forward
come on yeah Kinesis is good don't trust
you
oh this looks like some what did I just
get oh all right then
I think those are anti grab panels or
something I don't know I have no idea
was that electric charge all right then
what is this uh-huh
okay
Oh
okay I got the key to the officers
quarters or something and now I have
that I can get back there and get the
codes but actually I pass no you know
you get the [ __ ] off of them
this force gun is good for those little
guys I'll tell you that
all right I'm actually all out of time
for this part hope you're all enjoying
dead space as much as I am so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye thing to make a
dramatic roof coming up oh yeah
Oh